You can feel the energy
>> Innovations.
>> Silicon Valley.
>> Design thinking.
>> Globally recognized experts.
>> It's truly diverse group.
>> A new way of thinking that I
can take back to our corporation.
>> Part of the issue that managers
face is that the world changes.
It's changing so rapidly that the folks
who are actually doing the managing don't
have time to sort of sit back and
think how might I do this better.
>> We've become very biased
in our decision-making,
in our assessments,
based on the environment we live in.
And so it's incredibly important to step
back, to step out of that comfort area,
hear different perspectives,
hear different ideas and
do a check on what do I really
know versus what I think I know.
[MUSIC]
>> There is an atmosphere here that
fosters innovation, creativity and
allows you to get focused and
really concentrated in the learning and
in sharing experiences with the friends.
Every day, I see people thinking
about new ways to do things.
>> How do we serve customers?
How do we make money?
How do we make sure we
create a great culture?
And so the ability in a very intense
period of time where you really are able
to share best practices and build a great
network of people around the world.
>> [MUSIC]
>> My research largely
focuses on collective action,
how to get groups of people together to
innovate, to undertake large changes.
>> How do I scale my top management team?
We'll actually look at how do
you change a successful company?
Been hard to do.
[MUSIC]
>> The warmth that is provided from the
Stanford professors is really endearing.
[MUSIC]
>> In my negotiation class, I talk first
about the negotiation process itself
beyond an adversarial
win-lose kind of dynamic,
to try to get them to think about not
only value creation, but value claiming.
>> I have teams in five different
countries and seeing the different people
and their attitude towards negotiations
was very important for me.
[MUSIC]
>> Every time you think you cracked
the case, or you are on top of the issue,
you see another brilliant or
different or surprising point of view.
>> I once had an executive say to me, this
is a really interesting idea you have but
I could never take the time to do this.
And my response was because you're so
time stressed,
you absolutely need to be able to do this.
>> You have to stop and ask yourself, are
you really always at the top of your game?
Having that opportunity to step aside and
think about things differently, we get so
entrenched in our everyday work,
it's hard.
We're just trying to keep the game
going and this allows you the chance to
step back and say, is there
a different way of playing the game?
And there is.
[MUSIC]